I'm back from my monday morning hockey
and other people have deserted us so
it's you and me Galina we'll do our
video people seem to appreciate this
sort of you know we used to call it in
hockey the hot stove league because in
the old days people who play hockey
outdoors and then they would come in
there was a hot stove with a fire there
sure in Russia the same and people would
sit around the hot stove and talk about
the Maquis so it's like a hot story what
interests me is motivation right now my
motivation for Korean is sagging a bit
however I get out of my hockey look on
my on my iPhone and my transcriber has
sent me to New transcripts Wow okay so I
said okay yeah so now I want to go home
and do them and it reminded me that you
know it's one thing to have that
motivation by your studying French I
like French I want to learn French I
want to learn to speak French there's
that kind of general motivation by the
time you kind of you know it's not
enough however if i get i have two
transcripts so that's very specific i
can go home now and do two transcripts
and I think sometimes it's easier if we
get a very simple task you know that we
have to do I agree because if you got
some kind of very general goal it's
really hard to to receive something like
and to reach this goal right for example
for my English when I excited English at
school and university I think maybe uh I
could I'd know enough motivation alone
in English but when I decided to
immigrate to canada right I got this
motivation with this world I knew that
yeah I I had to learn because I had to
communicate with other people in English
your info is amazing it really is you
won't even eat my hat very true how many
years oh yeah oh I mean that's
tremendous but still okay yeah there's
lots of immigrants here who say I should
learn English because my let's say they
have kids in school can't speak the
teacher you never know you might get
stopped by a policeman which I was today
by the way
that's another story but so you need to
put them they don't so what is that
that's my say sometimes you have that
like I know that tonight I have to speak
to my Korean tutor that gets me going or
I get these do transcripts that you need
that some kind of specific training so
in the case of your English did just the
fact that you were going to immigrate to
Canada that was enough to keep you
motivated yes because i really i really
want to communicate well with people
need to be understood by other people
and they'll understand other people
right it's essential oh yeah if you
happy of yours and also I think maybe
people should have water specific time
frames learning from sample you you say
that you have a conversation today so
you you have very specific target and a
specific time even for our 90 day
challenge right so we have this specific
time period and we try to stand track
and don't and when you say like okay I'm
going to start learning English on
Monday it will never happen right yeah
tomorrow I'll start tomorrow ya need for
a specific target motivation and kind of
time time frame yeah and you know and
that's what we try to do at link to
because you know we have these known
words total and people say what's a
known word it doesn't matter I sometimes
compared it to you know when they have
dog races have a mechanical rabbit and
the dogs chase I have take mechanical
rabbit so you need something like that
to to keep you going on the subject of
the policeman ah i was driving it was an
80 kilometer an hour zone and I have you
know I bought a new car oh it's I don't
have to do anything at speeds so I was
going 124 it turns out so please man
comes at me he's got his gun he says you
know you went up two hundred twenty
eight kilometers an hour but i have
recorded here out of 24
in here lies the driver's license habla
goes away comes back ask me my birthdate
if I still live at the same address that
he says that he says today I'm going to
give you the speech instead of the
ticket he said he said if you had been
going two kilometers faster like if I
had been going 130 at the past this
point said we would have taken your car
for seven days we want to find you three
hundred and fifty dollars the towing
your car blah blah blah and then you
would be you would get the designation
of a dangerous driver therefore your
insurance would go up by autonomic I
mean that whole exercise would have cost
me I don't know a couple of thousand
dollars listen from now on I drive
slowly I don't know how that applies to
language journey we gotta figure some
way we can use that rely on your journey
anyway so today's my lucky day you know
what just on that something I was having
lunch of that Korea rest that Japanese
run by career where I sit at the bar and
I talked to the Koreans behind the
counter and this lady sits down beside
me because she's ordered some takeout
and so and then a friend of Jason you
know Jason Jenny's so he shows up and
we're talking about this and I said yeah
I had this I almost got a ticket and she
said well I got that ticket and she had
her car impounded for sale and all the
rest of it so it can't its move anyway
drive carefully all you language
learners